hey youtubers is Charlie doctor who week
continues with my list of top five
companions I also have details on the
second 50th anniversary mini episode the
last day as well as the other videos
that mean my friends are doing this week
as we countdown to the 50th anniversary
episode be sure to subscribe to get
everything so let's start with number 5
Captain Jack Harkness so Captain Jack
was such an awesome companion that
Russell T Davies allowed him to survive
dying during a parting of ways and he's
one of the only companions to get his
own spin-off in Torchwood and to try and
go on and shag the entire universe
anything that moves Captain Jack is
actually the creation of both Russell T
Davies who is showrunner at the time of
his inception and Steven Moffat who
wrote his first episode the empty child
number 4 Amy Pond
so her inception was so amazing she
basically turned the doctor into the
world's best imaginary friend and then
went on to become one of the best
gingers on the show ever
she was so fearsome that I feel like in
an alternate reality she is Donna nobles
younger sister once her fiance Rory
became a companion the show turned into
this funny Three's Company relationship
comedy that resulted in the birth of the
doctor's future wife River Song I feel
like Amy's departure was one of the more
heartbreaking ones especially in recent
years not only did she jump off a
building to save everyone
she jumped back into a sharks pit of
weeping angels just to be with Rory it's
totally ok if you want to cry now a
little bit number three Rose Tyler so
Rose was the ultimate introduction to
Doctor Who especially for new fans
she was so popular that she went on to
survive multiple doctors and I feel like
her relationship with the doctor
especially of all the modern companions
was definitely the most intense because
her run was so memorable
Russell T Davies not only gave her her
own version of immortal doctor to live
out the rest of her days with in an
alternate reality I feel like a lot of
later companions ended up getting
benchmarked against her she is also
directly responsible for giving number 5
Captain Jack Harkness his curse of
immortality
she's also appearing in the 50th
anniversary episode although it's
believed that she's not appearing as
Rose Tyler but as bad wolf number 2
Donna Noble so Donna was the perfect
follow-up to Rose how do you cure broken
heart with comedy and whenever Catherine
Tate joined the show she was basically
at the height of her comedy power she
had this sketch show that had been
running at the same time so she was
amazingly popular and the show ended up
turning into this really funny buddy-cop
flick but Donna ended up
me what I feel like was the doctors best
friend of all the companions I feel like
the way Donna became a companion was
definitely the funniest an time for my
number one companion Sarah Jane Smith so
she is the companion that all other
companions both classic and modern are
compared against she was so popular that
she got not one but two spin-off shows
she ended up being used again during
modern who by Russell T Davies during
series two to kind of bridge the gap
between classic and modern new fans she
ended up helping multiple doctors and
were Elisabeth Sladen still alive today
I think she would definitely be in the
50th anniversary episode and one of her
doctors the Fourth Doctor Tom Baker is
actually confirmed to have a cameo in it
so look forward to some Sarah Jane
references whenever he appears on screen
but like a lot of my other top 5 list
there were so many awesome companions
that I had to leave off please post your
alternate top 5 in the comments below
and onto the 50th anniversary so like I
said the second mini episode for the
50th anniversary has just posted the
last day it chronicles the fall of
Arcadia on Gallifrey during the time war
the BBC actually posted it free on
iTunes so you can actually go download
it now speaking of free stuff you also
still have time to join my Doctor Who
50th anniversary DVD giveaway I'll have
links to that in the description you can
also get information about the
livestream we're doing on Saturday in
that video too right now check out all
the other awesome Doctor Who videos my
friends are doing this week by clicking
on some of these annotations thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
you